Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on CaseFiles Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and ad-free, you can support case file on your preferred platform.
我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您在应用程序或我们网站上该剧集的节目说明。本剧集最初是在 CaseFiles 的 Patreon、Apple Premium 和 Spotify Premium 订阅源上作为付费订阅者的早期奖励发布的。这些剧集旨在缩短时长，以便我们涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前且无广告地收听这些剧集，您可以在您偏好的平台上支持 Casefile。
Tuesday, August 15, 1989 was a very hot summer's day in California's Central Valley. Joseph Villa, not his real name, was driving near the 205 Highway in Stockton. with his wife and son when their car overheated. Joseph pulled over on a quiet side road and propped up the car's bonnet to inspect the damage. Realising it was too severe to fix without assistance, Joseph decided he and his son would walk to the nearest payphone to call for help while his wife waited at the car.
1989年8月15日，星期二，是加利福尼亚州中央谷地一个非常炎热的夏日。约瑟夫·维拉（化名）当时正带着妻子和儿子在斯托克顿的205号高速公路附近开车，这时他们的车过热了。约瑟夫把车停在一条安静的侧路上，撑起引擎盖检查损坏情况。意识到如果不寻求帮助就无法修复，约瑟夫决定他和儿子步行去最近的公用电话亭求助，而他的妻子则在车里等待。
As the father and son headed down the dusty road in search of a phone, the boy noticed an old military fatigue. jacket in a camouflage print crumpled on the ground. A military-style unit patch was crudely sewn on it. He kicked at the jacket and revealed an unmarked VHS cassette tape bundled underneath. Curious about what might be on there, he and his dad took it with them to watch later. At home, the Villa family inserted the videotape into their VCR and hit play. They gathered around the television. It appeared to contain footage of a home movie.
当父子俩沿着尘土飞扬的道路寻找电话时，男孩注意到地上有一件皱巴巴的迷彩印花旧军用夹克。上面粗糙地缝着一个军用风格的部队徽章。他踢了踢夹克，露出了下面捆着的一盘未标记的 VHS 录像带。出于好奇，他和父亲把它带上，打算以后再看。回到家后，维拉一家把录像带放进录像机并按下播放键。他们围在电视机前。录像里似乎是家庭录像的片段。
Whoever had shot it had done so outside at night. Most of their surroundings were shrouded in darkness, but in the centre of the screen, a short distance away from the cameraman, was a single-story ranch house. The entire building was on fire. Crackling sounds could be heard as the blaze overwhelmed the house's timber frame. The person behind the camera was clearly eager to record every second of the building's destruction. A male voice appeared in the background, seemingly narrating the unfolding disaster.
拍摄者是在晚上户外拍摄的。大部分环境都笼罩在黑暗中，但在屏幕中央，离摄影师不远的地方，有一栋单层牧场式房屋。整栋建筑都在燃烧。当大火吞噬房屋的木框架时，可以听到噼啪作响的声音。镜头后面的人显然急于记录下建筑被毁的每一秒。背景中出现了一个男人的声音，似乎在解说这场正在发生的灾难。
His voice was hushed and his tone excited. Look at it. Look at the planet. This is my domain. My hair on me. I call hell my hair. The whole sky is black with smoke. It's joy of soul up. Anxious and that's the evil. It seemed as though the person who had filmed the fire was also the one responsible for starting it.
他的声音很低沉，语气很兴奋。“看着它。看着这个星球。这是我的领地。我的头发在我身上。我称地狱为我的头发。整个天空都被烟雾染黑了。这是灵魂的喜悦。焦虑，这就是邪恶。” 拍摄火灾的人似乎也是纵火的始作俑者。
He began addressing somebody he called Omar. Look at it, Omar. This is what I've been doing. In a week's vacation, I said I'll do it. I said I'll do it. Soon, sirens could be heard as firefighters rushed to the scene. Their loud, wailing noise seemed to prompt neighborhood coyotes to howl in reply. The unseen narrator behind the camera continued to narrate the scene. The fire department was trying to put it out.
他开始对一个他称之为奥马尔的人说话。“看着它，奥马尔。这就是我一直在做的事。在一周的假期里，我说我会做到的。我说我会做到的。” 很快，随着消防员赶到现场，可以听到警笛声。他们那响亮、凄厉的噪音似乎引得附近的土狼嚎叫回应。镜头后面那个看不见的人继续解说着现场。消防部门正试图扑灭大火。
What a laugh. Look out, but remember me tonight. Ladies and gentlemen, I'm just next. The tape then shifted to footage from the horror film A Nightmare on Elm Street, recorded straight off a televised airing. It wasn't clear if the Inferno footage had been taped over the movie or edited in for a reason. The Villa family were shocked and wasted no time in passing the tape along,
“真是可笑。小心点，但今晚记住我。女士们先生们，我就是下一个。” 随后，录像切换到了恐怖电影《猛鬼街》的片段，直接从电视转播中录制。目前尚不清楚地狱火的录像是否覆盖了电影，还是出于某种原因被剪辑进去的。维拉一家感到震惊，并立即将录像带交给了当局。
to the authorities. Arson investigators at California's Department of Forestry took responsibility for the case. One of them went back to where the villas had found the tape. The fatigue jacket was still there. Wrapped up inside the garment were a few audio cassettes featuring heavy metal music. Lying nearby was a single glove in the same camouflage print as the jacket. The investigator also discovered a small ceramic skull and a wooden pestle of the type used to grind and crush herbs. As it was 1989, investigators suspected these latter two items suggested some kind of occult connection.
加州林业部的纵火调查人员接手了此案。其中一人回到了维拉一家发现录像带的地方。那件迷彩夹克还在那里。包裹在衣服里的是几盘重金属音乐的音频磁带。附近躺着一只与夹克同款迷彩印花的手套。调查人员还发现了一个小陶瓷头骨和一个用于研磨和粉碎草药的木杵。由于当时是1989年，调查人员怀疑后两件物品暗示了某种神秘的联系。
Throughout the 1980s and early 90s, many law enforcement agencies in the United States were swept up in what later became known as the Satanic Panic, a fear that groups of people who worshipped the Christian figure of the devil were committing crimes around the country. The investigators responsible for looking into the Stockton Arsonist tape had noted the arsonists' frequent references to hell and evil. They suspected the ceramic skull was some kind of demonic talisman, and the pestle might have been used in satanic rituals. Investigators just weren't sure why the videotape had been left with the other items by the side of the road. Maybe the perpetrator had stashed them there and intended to return, or perhaps he felt a thrill at the thought of his work being discovered and wanted it to be found. The best hope investigators had of getting to the bottom of the case was to review the tape for evidence.
在整个20世纪80年代和90年代初，美国许多执法机构都卷入了后来被称为“撒旦恐慌”的事件中，这是一种担心崇拜基督教魔鬼形象的群体在全国各地犯罪的恐惧。负责调查斯托克顿纵火犯录像带的调查人员注意到纵火犯频繁提到地狱和邪恶。他们怀疑陶瓷头骨是某种恶魔护身符，而木杵可能被用于撒旦仪式。调查人员只是不确定为什么录像带和其他物品会被留在路边。也许肇事者把它们藏在那里并打算回来取，或者他可能对自己的作品被发现感到兴奋，并希望它被找到。调查人员破案的最大希望是审查录像带以寻找证据。
The fact that the arsonist often spoke in a stage whisper made it difficult to understand much of what he said, so investigators watched the tape over and over again and painstakingly crafted a transcript of the audio. The repeated references to someone called Omar caught their attention. They theorized that maybe Omar was the arsonist's term for the devil, or perhaps he even used it as slang for the police. The idea that the arsonist could actually be saying Omar, the German word for grandmother, was also floated. But the most popular theories were that Omar was someone's name, possibly the owner of the house shown burning on the film. Investigators noted that on the left side of the screen there was a white trailer by a neighbouring property.
由于纵火犯经常用舞台耳语说话，很难听懂他所说的大部分内容，因此调查人员一遍又一遍地观看录像带，并费力地制作了音频誊本。反复提到一个叫奥马尔的人引起了他们的注意。他们推测奥马尔可能是纵火犯对魔鬼的称呼，或者他甚至用它作为警察的俚语。纵火犯实际上是在说“Omar”（德语中祖母的意思）的想法也被提了出来。但最流行的理论是奥马尔是一个人的名字，可能是电影中被烧毁房屋的主人。调查人员注意到屏幕左侧有一辆邻近房产的白色拖车。
This suggested that the ranch house set a light had actually been under construction at the time. Maybe Omar was the head of the building crew and the arsonist was one of his labourers. If the arsonist had been fired by Omar, then that could point to a motive of revenge. What they really needed to uncover was the property's location. If they could pinpoint a specific address, then they would be on their way to solving the case. Investigators tried to zoom in on the house to see if a street name or number was visible, but they were unable to spot anything. The arsonist had filmed the moment that firefighters arrived,
这表明被点燃的牧场式房屋当时实际上正在施工中。也许奥马尔是建筑工队的负责人，而纵火犯是他的劳工之一。如果纵火犯被奥马尔解雇了，那可能指向复仇的动机。他们真正需要发现的是房产的位置。如果他们能确定具体的地址，那么他们就能破案了。调查人员试图放大房屋画面，看看是否能看到街道名称或门牌号，但他们什么也没发现。纵火犯拍摄了消防员到达的那一刻，
so the investigators also tried enhancing footage of their truck. Perhaps they could see some kind of identification number or county name emblazoned on the vehicle. Once again, they had no success. The property was a single-story ranch house with two chimneys, and it appeared to have been under construction at the time it was burnt. Investigators combed through reports of house fires in the region to see if anything fit the bill, but found no matches.
所以调查人员也试图增强他们卡车的画面。也许他们能看到印在车上的某种识别号码或县名。再一次，他们没有成功。该房产是一栋带两个烟囱的单层牧场式房屋，在被烧毁时似乎正在施工。调查人员梳理了该地区的房屋火灾报告，看看是否有符合条件的，但没有找到匹配的。
They began to wonder whether the blaze had even taken place in California. The 205 highway was just a few yards from where the tape was found, and it linked to several other major highways that stretched out across the country. Investigators began to worry that they might never find the person responsible for what they had dubbed the Omar fire. This thought concerned more than one of them. Frank Curry, a fire captain at the California Department of Forestry, had been so disturbed by the footage of the tape that he'd struggled to sleep after first
他们开始怀疑这场大火是否真的发生在加利福尼亚州。205号高速公路距离发现录像带的地方只有几码远，它连接着全国各地的其他几条主要高速公路。调查人员开始担心他们可能永远找不到那个被称为“奥马尔火灾”的责任人。这个想法让不止一个人感到担忧。加州林业部的消防队长弗兰克·库里对录像带中的画面感到非常不安，以至于他在第一次观看后就难以入睡。
watching it. Doug Allen, a law enforcement coordinator at the department, feared that the person responsible could go on to commit further more violent crimes. He was well aware that some of the law enforcement coordinator at the department, fear that the person responsible, criminals, such as New York serial killer son of Sam, had started their crime sprees with arson before moving on to murder. Doug Allen, quote, I think the person who made this videotape and is responsible for the fire will, without a doubt in my mind, continue to set fires.
该部门的执法协调员道格·艾伦担心，责任人可能会继续犯下更暴力的罪行。他很清楚，一些罪犯，例如纽约连环杀手“山姆之子”，在转向谋杀之前都是从纵火开始犯罪狂潮的。道格·艾伦说：“我认为制作这段录像带并对火灾负责的人，毫无疑问会继续纵火。”
And the person needs to be apprehended and stopped before his fires become more destructive. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Investigators spent a year trying to figure out the location of the fire, but finally accepted that they had hit a dead end. Realising that the media might be one way they could generate some leads,
“必须在火灾变得更具破坏性之前将此人逮捕并制止。” Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供优质内容。调查人员花了一年时间试图找出火灾地点，但最终承认他们陷入了死胡同。意识到媒体可能是产生线索的一种方式，
they approached the producers of the primetime television program Unsolved Mysteries. As well as featuring stories about missing persons and unexplained paranormal phenomena, the series explored unsolved crimes. Viewers at home were encouraged to call in to the show's hotline with any information they might have. The show's producers were keen to cover the Omar fire. Some of the case investigators, including Doug Allen and Frank Curry appeared on camera to discuss their concerns. The show also depicted a reenactment of how the mysterious and disturbing videotape was found.
他们联系了黄金时段电视节目《未解之谜》的制片人。除了讲述失踪人口和无法解释的超自然现象的故事外，该系列还探索了未解之谜。鼓励观众拨打节目的热线电话提供他们可能掌握的任何信息。节目的制片人很想报道奥马尔火灾。包括道格·艾伦和弗兰克·库里在内的一些案件调查人员出现在镜头前讨论他们的担忧。节目还重现了神秘而令人不安的录像带是如何被发现的。
The episode aired on the night of Wednesday, September 19, 1990. As Ed Tarantino sat in his Redwood City home, approximately 80 miles west of where the villa family had found the tape, a wave of shock washed over him. The house shown burning on his television screen was the very same one that sat behind his own. It had been under construction when the fire spread more than two years earlier on August 15, 1988, and was subsequently rebuilt. Although Ed had been aware of the destructive blaze,
该剧集于1990年9月19日星期三晚上播出。当埃德·塔兰蒂诺坐在他红木城的家中时，距离维拉一家发现录像带的地方大约80英里，一股震惊感席卷了他。电视屏幕上显示的被烧毁的房子正是他家后面那栋。它在两年多前的1988年8月15日火势蔓延时正在施工，随后被重建。虽然埃德知道那场破坏性的大火，
the existence of a creepy video of the entire thing came as a disturbing surprise. He called the Unsolved Mysteries Hotline, Ed wasn't the only viewer who recognised the property. Bill Otterley was a contractor who'd struggled with constructing a house back in the summer of 1988. The residence he had been building was a 4,200 square foot home in Redwood City's Emerald Lake Hills neighbourhood. It was an expensive undertaking, with the house valued at $850,000. Just after the home's plywood wall, were put up, the entire thing was burned down under the cover of night.
但存在一段关于整件事的恐怖视频是一个令人不安的惊喜。他拨打了《未解之谜》热线，埃德并不是唯一认出该房产的观众。比尔·奥特利是一位承包商，他在1988年夏天曾为建造一栋房子而苦恼。他正在建造的住宅是红木城翡翠湖山社区一栋4200平方英尺的房子。这是一项昂贵的工程，房屋价值85万美元。就在房子的胶合板墙立起来后，整栋房子在夜幕掩护下被烧毁了。
When Bill discovered what had happened, he had sat by the destroyed shell of a house and cried. The house was rebuilt, and during the second attempt at construction, Bill had paid an employee to stand guard over it at night. As Bill watched Unsolved Mysteries air footage of the fire that had stumped arson investigators over in Stockton, he recognised their house being destroyed by flames. He was watching his own property burn to the ground. In the days after the episode aired, the team at Unsolved Mysteries received a record-breaking 1,600 phone calls. Some offered theories about where the patch sewn on the fatigue jacket had originated from, or what it signified. Others called in from all over the country to report house fires they thought matched the one on the Stockton Arsoness tape.
当比尔发现发生了什么事时，他坐在被毁的房屋外壳旁哭泣。房子被重建了，在第二次施工尝试期间，比尔雇了一名员工在晚上守卫它。当比尔观看《未解之谜》播出斯托克顿纵火调查人员一直无法解决的火灾画面时，他认出了他们被火焰摧毁的房子。他正在看着自己的房产被烧成灰烬。在剧集播出后的几天里，《未解之谜》团队收到了创纪录的1600个电话。一些人提供了关于迷彩夹克上缝制的徽章起源或其含义的理论。其他人从全国各地打来电话，报告他们认为与斯托克顿纵火犯录像带相符的房屋火灾。
But it was the calls from the San Mateo County area that fascinated investigators the most. Three years earlier, in the summer of 1987, the Emerald Lake Hills neighbourhood near Redwood City began experiencing a spade of fires. All were started from gasoline and Molotov cocktails and as many as 30 blazers were thought to be connected to the attacks. Most of them burned out naturally before causing significant damage, but several had destroyed new homes that were under construction, including one belonging to Bill Otterly. San Mateo County investigators had a theory. They believed the arsonist was angry at the development of what had been a rural area.
但最让调查人员着迷的是来自圣马特奥县地区的电话。三年前，即1987年夏天，红木城附近的翡翠湖山社区开始出现一系列火灾。所有火灾都是由汽油和莫洛托夫鸡尾酒引发的，据信多达30起火灾与这些袭击有关。其中大多数在造成重大损失前自然熄灭，但有几起摧毁了正在施工的新房，包括属于比尔·奥特利的一栋。圣马特奥县的调查人员有一个理论。他们认为纵火犯对该地区的发展感到愤怒，因为这里曾经是一个农村地区。
A couple of years earlier, San Mateo County had received federal funding for a new sewer system, which led to increase to residential construction. It had come at the perfect time. The county was in the heart of Silicon Valley, which was rapidly growing alongside the technology companies based there. As more people moved to the area for work, more homes were needed and the region began to change. San Franciscans in search of space started to relocate
几年前，圣马特奥县获得了联邦资金用于新的下水道系统，这导致了住宅建设的增加。这来得正是时候。该县位于硅谷中心地带，随着当地科技公司的发展，硅谷正在迅速壮大。随着越来越多的人搬到该地区工作，需要更多的住房，该地区开始发生变化。寻找空间的旧金山人开始搬迁
to the quieter Redwood City and to Emerald Lake Hills. In November 1988, a 100-year-old cabin that was in the process of being turned into a luxurious house was burnt down. Investigators discovered that the arsonist had scrawled a message on a wall inside. Neighbors revolt. Please, no more new houses. Because the attacks had taken place across a five-square-mile area, authorities struggled to pinpoint a suspect. But now, several years after the fires began, it seemed that other investigators in a neighbouring county had found proof of the arsonist in the form of a disturbing videotape. As it happened, investigators in San Mateo County also had footage of the blaze that had destroyed Bill O'Darly's house.
到更安静的红木城和翡翠湖山。1988年11月，一栋正在被改造成豪华住宅的百年小屋被烧毁。调查人员发现纵火犯在里面的墙上潦草地写着一条信息：“邻居反抗。求求你们，不要再建新房子了。” 由于袭击发生在五平方英里的范围内，当局很难锁定嫌疑人。但现在，在火灾开始几年后，似乎邻县的其他调查人员以一段令人不安的录像带的形式找到了纵火犯的证据。碰巧的是，圣马特奥县的调查人员也有摧毁比尔·奥特利房子的火灾录像。
After setting up the command post and dispatching firefighters to put out the flames, the fire captain had set up a video camera to film the entire thing for investigative and training purposes. The recent outbreak of arson attacks had meant capturing one on tape was more important than ever. Investigators were able to compare the footage from the fire captain's video to that on the cassette found by the villa family. It confirmed that not only were they both of the same blaze, but that the firefighters had been standing just 50 feet away from. from the arsonist as he filmed his handiwork. Case File will be back shortly.
在建立指挥所并派遣消防员扑灭火焰后，消防队长架设了一台摄像机，为了调查和培训目的拍摄了整个过程。最近爆发的纵火袭击意味着在录像带上捕捉到一次纵火比以往任何时候都更重要。调查人员能够将消防队长的视频画面与维拉一家发现的录像带进行比较。这证实了它们不仅是同一场火灾，而且消防员在纵火犯拍摄他的杰作时，距离他只有50英尺远。 CaseFile 稍后回来。
Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. As well as helping pinpoint the fire's location, the involvement of unsolved mysteries led to another crucial clue. A woman named Doris Lance had also watched the episode as it aired. She too lived close to Bill Otterley's house and she remembered the fire well. But that wasn't the only thing that stood out to her about the creepy footage.
感谢您通过收听本剧集的赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本剧集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 CaseFile 继续提供优质内容。除了帮助确定火灾地点外，《未解之谜》的参与还带来了另一个关键线索。一位名叫多丽丝·兰斯的女士也在节目播出时观看了它。她也住在比尔·奥特利家附近，她对那场火灾记忆犹新。但这并不是让她对恐怖画面印象深刻的唯一原因。
The arsonist's repeated references to someone called Omar caught Doris's attention. She had a neighbour named Omar. He was a 17-year-old boy who lived with his family and had gotten into trouble on more than one occasion. Doris placed a call to investigators. When the teenager was chased down and interviewed, he quickly broke down under questioning. Omar explained that he had a friend who was two years older than him. The two of them had lit the fire together and filmed the entire thing. Omar had remained silent as the camcorder recorded everything.
纵火犯反复提到一个叫奥马尔的人引起了多丽丝的注意。她有一个邻居叫奥马尔。他是一个17岁的男孩，和家人住在一起，不止一次惹过麻烦。多丽丝给调查人员打了个电话。当这名少年被追捕并接受审讯时，他在审讯下很快崩溃了。奥马尔解释说，他有一个比他大两岁的同伙。他们俩一起放火并拍摄了整个过程。当摄像机记录一切时，奥马尔保持沉默。
His friend was the one who had narrated the blaze. Jason, not his real name, was 19 years old by the time he was brought to investigators' attention. They placed him under surveillance. During the period when they were observing Jason, the garage of his home happened to catch on fire and burnt down. As investigators combed through the rubble, they found several interesting things. There were knives and sores that appeared to be stained with blood, some mutilated animal remains, a table where items had clearly been cut up, and a mask featuring the face of Freddie Kruger, the villain from a nightmare on Elm Street.
他的朋友是那个解说火灾的人。杰森（化名）在引起调查人员注意时已经19岁了。他们对他进行了监视。在他们观察杰森期间，他家的车库碰巧着火并烧毁了。当调查人员搜查废墟时，他们发现了几件有趣的东西。有看起来沾有血迹的刀具和锯子，一些残缺的动物遗骸，一张显然用来切割物品的桌子，以及一个带有弗雷迪·克鲁格（《猛鬼街》中的反派）面孔的面具。
In the film, the spirit of Kruger seeks revenge on a group of teenagers, after their parents kill him by burning him alive in a boiler room. They light the fire with Molotov cocktails. Armed with the disturbing evidence recovered from Jason's garage, just over a week after the episode of Unsolved Mysteries aired, investigators hauled the 19-year-old inn for questioning. Just like Omar, Jason soon admitted to everything. He confirmed that he was behind the fire on the videotape
在电影中，克鲁格的灵魂在父母将他活活烧死在锅炉房后，向一群青少年寻求报复。他们用莫洛托夫鸡尾酒点燃了火。带着从杰森车库中找回的令人不安的证据，在《未解之谜》剧集播出仅一周多后，调查人员将这名19岁的年轻人带去审讯。就像奥马尔一样，杰森很快承认了一切。他证实他是录像带中火灾的幕后黑手，
and had filmed the entire thing. To investigators, Jason appeared to be a very troubled young man. At times he was sullen and withdrawn, but then he would start crying as he spoke about what he had done. Armed with a search warrant, investigators returned to Jason's home in search of further evidence. They discovered that the tape found in Stockton wasn't the only one he had made. Further tapes recovered from Jason's residence indicated he had followed news. news coverage of his fires. He had filmed a series of newspaper clippings that covered the arson attacks and pinned the articles to a wall. There was also footage of black spray paint on a wall
并拍摄了整个过程。在调查人员看来，杰森似乎是一个非常困扰的年轻人。有时他闷闷不乐、沉默寡言，但随后他会一边谈论他所做的事情一边哭泣。带着搜查令，调查人员回到杰森家寻找更多证据。他们发现斯托克顿发现的录像带并不是他制作的唯一一盘。从杰森住所找回的其他录像带表明他一直在关注新闻。他拍摄了一系列报道纵火袭击的报纸剪报，并将这些文章钉在墙上。还有一段墙上喷着黑色喷漆的录像，
that read, please, no more houses. This was reminiscent of similar graffiti found at the 100-year-old cabin burnt down in November 1988. There were also more home movies that he'd made with Omar. One showed Jason being filmed by Omar from behind. He had pulled his t-shirt up around the back of his neck to make it look like he had a hunchback, and he curled his hands to resemble claws. As Jason turned around to face the camera, he revealed that he was wearing a vampire mask. He had painted an upside-down cross on his forehead, and he snarled at the camera. In a different clip, Jason was wearing a vampire mask.
上面写着：“求求你们，不要再建房子了。” 这让人想起1988年11月在被烧毁的百年小屋中发现的类似涂鸦。还有更多他与奥马尔制作的家庭录像。其中一段显示杰森被奥马尔从后面拍摄。他把T恤拉到脖子后面，看起来像个驼背，并蜷起双手模仿爪子。当杰森转身面对镜头时，他露出戴着吸血鬼面具的样子。他在额头上画了一个倒十字，并对着镜头咆哮。在另一个片段中，杰森戴着吸血鬼面具，
wielded a knife at a dummy, which he addressed as father. After asking how the dummy was, he said, I hope you're doing real good. Then he stabbed it in the chest and used the knife to slice off its head. Dressed as Dracula, he gave a theatrical performance to the camera. Because the night is a night where all evil and satanic worshippers come, where Satan rises a 10 and fulfills the destiny of hatred and evil and sin. Another video showed Jason and Omar playing violent war-style games in a rural area,
挥舞着一把刀对着一个假人，他称之为“父亲”。在问假人怎么样后，他说：“我希望你过得很好。” 然后他刺向它的胸部，并用刀切下了它的头。他打扮成德古拉，对着镜头进行了戏剧性的表演。“因为夜晚是所有邪恶和撒旦崇拜者到来的夜晚，撒旦升起并实现了仇恨、邪恶和罪恶的命运。” 另一段视频显示杰森和奥马尔在一个农村地区玩暴力的战争游戏，
presumably the Emerald Lake Hills neighborhood. While some investigators have said that the two had no motive for the fires they lit, others have speculated that they were upset by the development of a region they clearly enjoyed spending time in. Authorities linked to Jason and Omar to the burning of 11 buildings and 15 separate grass fires. In total, their actions had caused more than $2 million in damage. Both suspects were tried as miners due to their respective ages at the time of the fires. Omar was sentenced to serve time in a juvenile detention facility, while Jason was sent to a mental health hospital in the hopes he would receive help and rehabilitation.
大概是翡翠湖山社区。虽然一些调查人员表示他们放火没有任何动机，但其他人推测他们对一个他们显然喜欢花时间待的地区的发展感到不满。当局将杰森和奥马尔与11栋建筑和15起独立草地火灾的焚烧联系起来。总的来说，他们的行为造成了超过200万美元的损失。由于两名嫌疑人在火灾发生时的年龄，他们都作为未成年人受审。奥马尔被判在少年拘留所服刑，而杰森被送往一家心理健康医院，希望他能得到帮助和康复。
Their identities have never been released by authorities or the media, and it is not publicly known what became of them after their sentencing. In the years since the episode of Unsolved Mysteries made the Stockton Arsonist case infamous, it has continued to generate discussion online, thanks mostly to the unsettling footage of the fire. According to online sleuths, who allegedly discovered... Jason's true identity, he died in January 2017 at the age of 45. Jason had been walking along a highway in San Mateo County when he tripped and stumbled onto the road.
他们的身份从未被当局或媒体公布，目前尚不清楚他们在判刑后发生了什么。在《未解之谜》剧集使斯托克顿纵火犯案件臭名昭著后的几年里，由于火灾令人不安的画面，它在网上持续引发讨论。据称发现了杰森真实身份的在线侦探称，他于2017年1月去世，享年45岁。杰森当时正走在圣马特奥县的一条高速公路上，当时他被绊倒并跌入路中。
He was struck by a passing car and pronounced dead at the scene. Although the young men's fires took place almost 90 miles away from Stockton in an entirely different part of California, the case has remained associated with the location. where the tape was discovered. It remains unclear how Jason and Omar's tape ended up in a place so far away from their homes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他被一辆经过的汽车撞倒，当场死亡。虽然这两个年轻人的火灾发生在距离斯托克顿近90英里的加利福尼亚州完全不同的地方，但该案件一直与发现录像带的地点联系在一起。目前尚不清楚杰森和奥马尔的录像带是如何最终出现在距离他们家这么远的地方的。此剧集尚无评论。点击誊本中的任何句子即可发表评论。